young Sigourney Weaver forget it's gonna
leave her now she can get it in general
but her and her younger age is like
fires what's up guys it's your boy
Dorian here so the collider staff gives
me crap all the time for not I've seen
old-ass movies I don't think it's my
fault because I'm young as hell and
they're they're actually old as dust I
decided to watch those Busters that I'm
tired of hearing their crap so here's my
review for a 1984 movie it was pretty
good like the villains and the ghosts
look like Power Ranger type villains so
I was all in for it and for it being
1984 he looked pretty quality it seemed
like they put a lot of money into that I
don't know man like just when they got
into the story it was you understood the
concept like within the first 15 minutes
all these other stories he try to get a
library try to build the mythology of it
but they just jump right into it and I
respected Bill Murray's character
because he wanted to get paid for his
services he's like I'm not gonna kill no
goes without getting my money so y'all
gonna pay me now or y'all just gonna
have to go with these ghosts I watched
this movie Adam Sandler movie pixels a
while back I was a little bit stoned
granted but they all have like their own
suits they got their own weapons the
city is cheering for them they're being
backed by the government's Adam Sandler
in pixels y'all kind of ripped off
ghostbusters I'm just saying that I'm
not gonna lie y'all rip that off in the
third act when there was like a like
when they shot all the ghosts around all
the city in the city was taken over
reminded me of Suicide Squad
so Ghostbusters inspired Suicide Squad
yes
I mean DC fans you know I love DC
releases AK sniper cut I love ghosts to
us there's more than Suicide Squad so
usually when it comes to
extra-terrestrial stuff you only see why
people doing that type of things so it
was kind of cool seeing a brother in
there fighting crime and doing all this
stuff like that seeing Bill Murray for
the first time looking so young you know
how Marvel does a digital DEA agent
technology it was like that that's what
another reason why I reminded me of
pixels Bill Murray's character trying to
get after her the whole time he Adam
Sandler trying to get after I don't know
her name but they ended up getting
together so I was like you know pixels
yelling sleep
right yeah you like that I did would you
think of Gollum uh-huh I think he's all
right like I thought he was okay like he
was pretty cool in ghostbusters yeah he
was all right wait did he get hit from
one of the ghosts I mean I I hope it
wasn't a dream because I'm just trying
to imagine like would you even feel it
like Oh like wait what's going on here
we're going with that are they really
allowing that but I don't know I thought
it was really funny oh hell yeah and
also so look III forgot about this like
everybody knows a theme song like we're
gonna call Ghostbusters and now I
actually feel like I earn like I earned
the right to sing that song now like I
was groovin by the anyone though when
the credits came around I was like who
you gonna call Ghostbusters and when I
hear that people say like are you gonna
call I'm gonna be like goes sorry you
can bleep that out sorry mom
oh wait the state the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man G watch legendre's
tomorrow there's a at the end of season
3 they turn into this big-ass giant blue
teddy bear so that I don't know why that
like I had that instant comparison but
he was kind of scary like I was probably
one of my other favorite characters it's
that big-ass white - - man walking
around I went to Texas State University
Halloween time I originally was going to
dress up as static but I was like nah
there was a cool Ghostbuster costume I
grabbed that because it had a big ass
like you know the the the the weapons
packed that they had because you could
store like beer and stuff in it and it
came with some sideburns I now looking
back at it is like I was a fool I should
have washed it a long last time ago if
you're my age or around my age and you
haven't seen the Ghostbusters movie just
because it's like older [ __ ] and you're
like why would I go see something like
that you're gonna really enjoy it it's a
simple story like easy to follow really
funny and it just it surpassed my
expectations because he doesn't go see
this movie you probably already seen
this movie you're just watching this to
see my comments but if you haven't seen
this movie go watch it because it's a
really good movie and if you have any
other like suggestions for movies you
want me to watch I haven't seen Jack
[ __ ] like I don't know why they hired me
but you know rome wasn't built in the
day I'm getting there
I haven't seen part 2 yet I've seen the
2016 version I know a lot of fans shy
you can talk about that
[Music]